The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, are
we ready to go?
Any questions on 18065?
So it will be, as I said before,
a mixture of linear algebra
and math questions, along with
online using the material.
OK.
So I'm, in this
first week or two,
reviewing the highlights
of linear algebra.
And I've reached this
point, to remember--
well, so we--
I just said two words
about multiplying matrices
by using column times
row as a way to do it.
And now, I want
to illustrate that
by the five key
factorizations of matrices.
OK.
So what are they?
And do you recognize them?
Everybody uses those letters.
In fact, some of those
letters, like LU or QR,
would be the most used MATLAB
commands in linear algebra.
So a A equal LU of, maybe--
say something I'll
develop today--
but it's about elimination.
Solving linear systems.
So that's always the start
of a linear algebra course.
But it will go fast here.
I just want to show
you a different way
they get to L times
U-- lower triangular
times upper triangular.
Probably you've seen that--
those triangular matrices.
So do you know what QR is?
What's QR about?
AUDIENCE: Least squares?
PROFESSOR: Least squares
is the big application,
the factorization.
So what kind of a matrix
gets that letter Q?
AUDIENCE: Orthogonal?
PROFESSOR: Orthogonal.
The columns are orthogonal.
Often orthonormal.
So orthogonal means they're
perpendicular to each other.
And orthonormal means
they're unit vectors.
So that is-- so Q often
represents a matrix
with orthonormal columns.
So you-- we could
say Gram-Schmidt,
if you want to remember
a couple of old timers
whose algorithm
produces Q and R.
How about this one?
This is really a
central one in math--
pure math, applied math,
everywhere-- applications.
So S stands for symmetric.
So this is a special
factorization
for symmetric matrices.
And you can see
that it's symmetric.
This lambda is the diagonal
eigenvalue matrix--
always lambda for eigenvalues.
Q is like that Q--
different Q, of course.
That Q you can find
just straight forward
from Gram-Schmidt.
This Q has the eigenvectors.
So you don't find eigenvectors
without some extra work.
OK.
So that's eigenvectors.
Yeah.
So that would be
worth expanding.
So here are the eigenvectors
of the matrix S--
n of them, normalized.
Here are the eigenvalues
lambda 1 to lambda n.
And here are the
eigenvectors now transposed.
So remind me of the
great fact about--
two facts, I guess-- one
fact about the eigenvalues
and one fact about eigenvectors.
This is an important fact
statement in linear algebra.
What do we know about
the eigenvectors?
Oh well, I guess
I've given it away.
The eigenvectors are orthogonal.
That's very important.
Makes some matrices-- well,
they're beautiful matrices.
They're the kings
of linear algebra.
Qs are the queens,
in my opinion.
Orthogonal matrices
are the queens,
and symmetric matrices
are the kings.
So these are orthonormal
eigenvectors.
And the key point--
an important point
that's implicit
here-- is, there are n of them.
There is a complete set.
The matrix can be diagonalized.
And those-- well, what's
special about the eigenvalues?
Other matrices could be
Q lambda Q transpose.
But symmetric matrices
are something additional
about lambda.
AUDIENCE: They're all real?
PROFESSOR: They're all real.
So eigenvalues are real.
And eigenvectors
are orthonormal--
can be chosen orthonormal--
can be chosen,
I guess I have to say.
OK.
Good.
Oh, now maybe I'll
use that as an example
of matrix multiplication.
So let me just do that here.
Simple matrix multiplication,
but it makes the point.
So Q lambda Q transpose.
OK.
Well, what was my point
about matrix multiplication?
Let me-- it really
involved two matrices.
Here, I unfortunately
have three.
So I'm going to have to squeeze
lambda in with one of the Qs,
to see it nicely
as two matrices.
Shall I just do that?
Yeah.
Now I've made it two matrices.
That was easy.
OK.
Now what's the rule?
In the first notes, this
was A and this was B.
And when you multiply
two matrices,
the rule is, this is
columns of Q lambda times
rows of Q transpose.
I'm multiplying columns by rows.
And so it's a column
vector times a row vector,
and that gives us a matrix.
So each-- and it's
a special matrix.
So this is our column.
This is a row.
And when I multiply n by 1 times
1 by n, I get an n by n matrix.
And it's pretty special.
And what is the
special fact about I'm
sort of recalling
from last time.
What's special about
a column times a row?
It's rank is special.
It's rank is 1.
It's column space-- well, the
only column around is this one.
So all columns are
multiples of this guy.
All rows are
multiples of this guy,
as we could see from an example.
Shall I just do an example?
1, 2 times 3, 4, to
take a random example.
So that would give
us 3, 4, 6, 8.
And sure enough, the columns
are multiples of 1, 2.
The rows are multiples of 3, 4.
And the rank is 1.
OK.
So those are the
building blocks.
Now I want to build something.
So here we go.
So this is a sum of rank 1.
Sum of rank 1.
Sum of column times row.
So I take column 1 times row 1.
That's my first
thing in the sum.
So column 1 of that.
So you see I had
to sneak the lambda
to have just two factors.
So what's column 1 of Q lambda?
That's a good question.
So column 1 of Q is Q1--
the first eigenvector.
But now, I am multiplying
by this diagonal matrix.
Do you see in your mind what's
the first column of Q lambda?
Just think about that a second.
So here's-- we can steal any
little corner for a matrix.
So here's q1, and the
rest of the columns.
And then here is lambda 1.
And that's Q lambda.
So I'm putting those together.
And I'm asking, what's the
first column of the answer?
Can you see how that works?
AUDIENCE: q1 lambda 1?
PROFESSOR: It's... sorry?.
PROFESSOR: q1 lambda 1.
Exactly.
That lambda 1 will multiply q1.
These other lambdas
multiplied later columns.
So the first column
is lambda 1 times q1.
Right.
So it's the first
guy, lambda 1, q1.
And then the first row of
this will be q1 transpose.
That's the first guy
in our sum of n things.
And let me put the next
one and the last one.
Lambda 2, q2, q2 transpose.
And lambda n, qn, qn transpose.
That's really a nice
right way to write
to breakup the product,
q lambda q transpose.
This is called the
spectral theorem.
So that's the symmetric-- that's
S. That's S there, is that.
So that's-- we've broken
up S into rank 1 pieces.
That's like a constant theme.
And these rank 1 pieces are
quite special because they're
symmetric.
Q1q1 transpose
will be symmetric.
And oh, so can we--
so let's just-- I follow the
rule for multiplying matrices.
But maybe I could just check
that it's the right thing--
that it came out right.
So what do I mean by checking?
I guess I'll just
check about S times q1.
So look at S--
this thing-- times the first
eigenvector, and what do I get?
OK.
So you'll like this.
I've split up S into a
sum of rank 1 pieces.
And that splitting is--
you see it all over.
It's really showing you what the
pieces of the symmetric matrix
are.
And now I'm just going
to check that that's
a correct formula for S,
so I'll multiply it by q1.
And I'm hoping to
get the right thing.
And what do I actually get?
If I multiply this
whole business times q1,
I get lambda 1,
q1, q1 transpose--
that's the first
guy times my q1--
plus-- right?
I'm multiplying S by q1, and
this first term gave me that.
And what does the
next term give me?
Put me out of my misery here.
I'm looking for this thing
to simplify like mad.
OK.
So what's the second term?
When I multiply this guy
by q1, what do I get?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
That's right.
That's what we want.
And when I multiply
the last guy by q1,
I get zero, because
the qs are orthogonal.
So this is all I get.
And then-- so, I don't
need this plus anymore.
That's it.
And then what can
I do to improve
that little somewhat repetitive
formula for the answer?
What do I want to do finally?
I want to remember that
the qs are normalized.
They're unit vectors.
So what does that tell me here?
AUDIENCE: Q1 transpose.
PROFESSOR: Q1
transpose times q1.
This is just 1.
It's-- that's what
normalized means--
that the length
squared is the length--
the length of the
vector squared.
And it's 1.
So I can cancel that term.
And I'm getting
the right answer.
That's all-- that's
all this was about.
I was just checking and wanted
to see how it would fall out.
And it falls right
out that this formula
is the correct matrix
S, because it's
got the right eigenvectors, qs.
And it's got the right
eigenvalues lambdas.
So it's gotta be the right
matrix S. Is that OK?
That's like a first
example to see how this--
splitting into rank 1s--
gives you back what you
expect easily enough.
It gives you the
information you expect.
OK.
So that's the symmetric
eigenvalue picture
for symmetric matrices.
And we'll see it again.
It's-- well, all five of
these are big, are important.
I don't know if
you know this one,
but it's going to be a
foundational factorization
for this course and for
all of data science.
Do you know its name?
So, what does it
mean, first of all?
Just a comment on
this, and then we'll
save it for a couple of weeks.
So this view is actually
an orthogonal matrix.
And so is V. So it has
two orthogonal matrices.
So that's why people
call them U and V
rather than Q1 and Q2, which
was too much to get subscript.
So orthogonal times
diagonal times orthogonal.
And we'd say, orthogonal,
diagonal, orthogonal.
And 18.06 would, as of
now, reach this topic
because it's jumped
up in importance.
And it's called?
AUDIENCE: Singular
value decomposition.
PROFESSOR: Singular
Well, those are long words, so
everybody calls it the SVD--
the singular value
decomposition.
The point is it works
for every matrix--
rectangular matrices.
There's no issue
of, does it have
enough eigenvectors or not?
That's an issue here.
Well, it's an issue here.
Not every matrix has got enough
eigenvectors to make that work.
Every matrix that one
works because instead
of one set of
vectors it's got two
matrices-- two different
sets of singular vectors.
Oh, we'll see that.
That's important.
OK.
So that's really
a quick overview
of fundamental factorizations.
And I'd like to say just
another word about elimination,
A equal LU, and then
we'll leave it alone.
So elimination.
Yeah.
Do you remember that first
beginning of linear algebra,
when you're solving ax equal b?
You do these row operations.
Can I just-- what I want to say
is, all those row operations
that you do are perfectly
expressed by L times U.
And so that's a
key point in 18.06,
but I have a different
way to look at it.
So that's what I
wanted to show you.
I have a--
I want to show you a sum of
rank 1's, or row times column.
It fits in today.
So I'd just like to see, why
does a matrix invertible--
this is a square
matrix, now invertible.
And it factors-- if all
goes well with elimination
and the pivots are non-zero--
it factors into lower triangular
times upper triangular.
So that's a key step that is--
that MATLAB would
do with a lu of A--
would produce those two factors.
Now I want to do them
in a column times row
way, which I just realized
late, was a neat way to do it.
So can I take a matrix
and do elimination?
How big a matrix shall I take?
2 by 2 [INAUDIBLE].
3 by 3 Somebody's not
convinced totally by 2 by 2
Let me do it 2 by 2 and then
if you want-- if you really
want a 3 by 3 do it.
OK.
Here's 2 by 2 2, 4, 3, 7.
How's that?
OK.
So what is-- yeah.
So let's remember
what elimination does.
It subtracts a multiple
of that row from that one,
to get to 2, 3.
And the multiple is 2.
So it knocks out the 4.
Two 3's are 6.
So it leaves a 1.
And we're-- oh, yeah.
Thanks for allowing
me to do 2 by 2.
I've already done it now.
I've reached U. So
here's A. And here's U--
the upper triangular guy with
the pivots on the diagonal.
And then the
question is, express
that step in matrix language.
And the right answer is l
times U. So the right answer
is that this A is--
so I'll just erase
that letter U--
is l times U. So what is l?
L is the lower triangular guy.
And it has there the
number that you used here.
And what was that?
I subtracted 2 of
that row from this.
So I want a 2 there.
So that would be--
I would call that a multiplier.
I multiplied row 1 by 2.
Subtracted to get that 0.
And for a 2 by 2
example, I was finished.
OK.
Now I want to see this--
so there is l times
U. It happened.
Right.
I would like to see how l
times U comes out of this row--
column times row.
So let me start--
let me think again.
So really the point
of elimination--
why did we do this
in the first place?
Because here we had
two coupled equations.
There were coupled together.
We couldn't solve
them instantly.
That step of elimination
reduced me to--
down here in this corner--
one equation, that I've
eliminated the first unknown x
from the second equation.
So the second equation is 0x
plus 1y equal right hand side.
And I solve it immediately.
OK.
So how did I get to
that 1 by 1 problem,
with these guys removed?
Well-- yeah.
I'll just write-- can
I write here the--
my parallel way to think of it?
2 by 2 is pretty small, I admit.
OK.
So I start with 2, 3, 4, 7.
I want to split it into--
I want to get the first row
and column in one piece.
Something goes there.
And the other piece
is something there.
OK.
That's what
elimination has done.
It's taken the original matrix.
It's split-- these
are both rank 1.
So let's just--
first of all, you
could tell me what goes in that
blank space in the first rank 1
matrix.
So what-- can I
say this in words?
The first stage of
elimination pulls off from A--
so A is some big matrix.
It pulls off from A. It takes
account of the first column
and row.
So it writes A as--
here we go-- as a first
column, say column
1, row 1, plus the easy part.
The easy part will be a
matrix with all zeros there--
all zeros there.
And here I have a 2.
Can I call it a 2?
This is my way now
to think about what
elimination is really doing.
It's starting with
an n by n matrix.
It's pulling off
a rank 1 matrix,
which gets that column
and that row correct.
And it gets whatever
it has in here.
And then the rest of
what's in there is A2.
Do you see that
we've done that here?
The first step got the first
row and column correct.
And if it's rank 1,
what number goes there?
AUDIENCE: 6.
PROFESSOR: 6.
6 for there.
And then this is the rest.
This is what we have, one
size smaller to work on.
And it looks like it was 7.
6 has been used.
So it's a 1.
That's really-- I want to
think of this rank 1 matrix
as the first column of l
times the first row of u.
And then this guy
is the second column
of l times the second row of u.
OK.
I haven't presented as
proof in a class before.
And for 2 by 2, it's
looking like overkill to me.
I mean, why?
You don't have to do
all that deep thinking
to get the pieces.
But my idea is that it
gives the breakdown.
And this, of course,
is, by our column times
row rule, that's LU.
So we're starting with A, and
we're breaking it up into LU,
where lu--
the first piece of lu--
is the first column times row.
And then the next pieces
are the rest of the matrix.
And those get broken down-- the
next stage of elimination would
break--
if I had a 3 by 3,
this stage peeled off
the first column and row--
then the next stage would
peel off the second--
the new second column and row.
And the third stage would have
the third column and row--
just the last pivot does
this make any sense to you?
You could email me and
say it's not that great.
But I think it's--
to see that the final result of
elimination is l times u is--
there's a little magic in
seeing what you're doing.
And I think this is a way
to see what you're doing--
that you're peeling
off a first part
to leave a second
part like that.
Then the second part,
you would peel off
the second column
times the second row,
maybe divide by the
pivot to make it correct.
And that would put something
in the rest of the box.
And then A3 would be
the rest of that box.
OK.
I'm stopping here.
I'm glad you let me do 2 by
2, since I see that 3 by 3
would have ruined the day.
Yeah.
OK.
A question, or let me
pause for a minute.
So I've talked about
these factorizations.
This one we won't see again.
This one we will see, big time.
And this one we will.
Yeah.
2, 3 and 5 are the
ones that we're really
going to see a lot of.
Questions or thoughts or--
OK.
I guess I want to tell you
now to complete today's--
moving forward in this subject--
the fundamental theorem
of linear algebra--
of linear algebra.
OK.
Ready for that?
Or you may have seen it
already, because it's
like the highlight
of this subject--
of the basic ideas
in this subject.
Right.
And then maybe I can--
after I tell you that theorem--
people around the world send
me homework problems to do.
Now, you would think any
sensible professor would never
do those problems.
He would say, it's your problem.
But I get carried away and
I solve them sometimes.
So one came from
India last week,
and it involved the fundamental
theorem of linear algebra.
Whoever teaching it there
really was on the ball.
And well, I'll tell
you that problem
after the fundamental theorem.
OK.
Fundamental theorem.
It's about four sub spaces.
So I invented the name four
fundamental sub spaces.
So can I list the
four sub places?
Fundamental sub spaces.
Well, we know one
of them already.
The column space--
so, for a matrix.
We are given a matrix A--
that's m by n of rank r.
That's our normal
starting point.
So what are those
four sub spaces,
and how are they related?
And what's their dimension?
And what-- those are key facts.
OK.
We already know
the column space--
column space of a matrix.
And actually, we already know
the row space of a matrix.
And we have the
notation for that,
column space of A transpose.
And what is the dimension--
so that was the key point
in the first lecture.
Anybody who missed
the first lecture,
should go back to
the notes of 1.1
for the thinking that goes
into the dimension equals what?
Which of those three
numbers do I want to--
is the dimension of
the column space?
R. And what can I say
about r, right away,
compared to m and n?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Less or equal.
r couldn't-- I couldn't have
more independent columns than I
have columns.
So I've got n columns.
So r of them are independent.
So r is somewhere, less or
equal-- hopefully equal to n.
What about the dimension
of the row space?
How many independent
rows has the matrix got?
AUDIENCE: R.
PROFESSOR: R. Thank you.
That's the great fact
with a new proof last time
in section 1.1--
that those have the same
dimension, same dimension.
Which is-- you think, oh, OK.
You look at a simple example.
It's true.
But if you're given a
matrix that's 50 by 100,
really the fact that
those 100 columns
have the same number of
independent ones as those 50
row--
that's like great.
OK.
Now the other spaces
are the null space
of the matrix, N of A.
And just to make everything
naturally symmetric,
the null space of A transpose.
Those are the last two.
Those are the four fundamental
sub spaces, which you've seen.
And they're even on the cover
of the linear algebra textbook.
OK.
So what's the null space?
AUDIENCE: It's the
set of [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: It's the
set of solutions to Ax
equals 0, right.
Null space is all
solutions to Ax equal 0.
So the null space has vector--
these vectors in it-- the x's.
The null space isn't
taken from the matrix.
The row space and the
column space-- those numbers
are sitting in the matrix.
The null space, and the
null space of A transpose,
are solutions to--
the word null is reflecting
the fact that that's a 0.
And that's what
makes it a space.
Now can you just--
let me just ask
you to think again.
What's implied when I say--
when I use the word space--
a space of vectors?
AUDIENCE: Closed
under addition--
PROFESSOR: I can add--
yeah.
So I can do the most important
operations of linear algebra
in that space.
I can add two vectors.
Here, let me just add them.
So here I'll have
a vector x, and let
me say another one, a vector y.
Then, I do addition.
I follow the rules.
I see that this can be written
as Ax plus y is 0 plus 0.
So what have I learned?
I've learned that if x
is in the null space,
and y is in the null
space, then x plus y.
So the null space is,
as you said, closed,
meaning I don't go outside it.
If x is in it, and y is in
it, then the sum is in it.
And similarly, from Ax equals
0, I get to A times cx equals 0.
Just multiply by
c-- by a number c.
So those two facts--
that means I can
do linear algebra.
I can multiply by numbers.
And I can add.
In other words, I can
take linear combinations.
That's what you do with vectors.
And the point is, if I do it--
if I take combinations
of two null space guys,
I'm still in the null space.
OK.
So that's the point
of the null space.
And-- well now-- so now part
of the fundamental theorem
is to figure out how many
independent vectors are
in the null space.
How many solutions--
independent solutions--
does that system
of equations have?
So that would be the dimension.
And I have to ask
you what it is.
Let me draw a
picture, while you're
thinking about those spaces.
It's fantastic to have these
beautiful clean boards.
OK.
So here's my picture
of the row space.
Row-- that's the column
space of A transpose.
And here's my picture of
the null space, N of A.
And that's the solutions
to Ax equals 0.
And why have I put
these two together,
and these two together?
So-- and the other pair will
be the column space, C of A.
and the null space
of A transpose.
So there are the four spaces.
Their relationship is
the fundamental theorem
of linear algebra.
So first of all, what--
so I have an m by n matrix.
So that tells me that my row--
a typical row has n
components, right?
I look at an m by n matrix.
Let's do a 2 by 3 matrix.
So if I look at the
row space, this is m.
And this is n.
So I see three--
the rows have length three.
And of course, they
multiply the x's,
which also have the
length three, x1, x2, x3.
That's why these are
together, because they're
both in n dimensional space.
Then why are these together?
Because the columns are
in two dimensional space,
for this example.
And the null space
of A transpose
would be just two components,
like y1 and y2, to give 0s.
So do you see that this is R--
these guys are in Rn?
So that's the first--
get things straight.
Two spaces in Rn,
two spaces in Rm.
Now, what am I going to
ask about these spaces?
I guess I've already
started asking
and didn't wait for an answer.
Their dimension.
So this has dimension R.
And what's the dimension--
how many-- this is
really such a key fact.
If I have m equations,
Ax equals 0.
And if R of those
equations are independent,
how many solutions?
So the dimension
of this space is
going to tell me
how many solutions
to Ax in two m
equations, but really
only are genuine independent
equations in this system Ax
equals 0.
How many?
So can I ask the question again?
And I want the answer in terms
of m, and n, and R. So I have--
I really have R equations.
If I look at Ax
equals 0, it looks
like m separate equations.
But m minus R--
of those-- are just copies
or combinations of others.
So there are
independent equations.
So what's-- how many have I got?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And And that's what
I'm going to write in here.
So-- yeah.
So x has n components.
And there are real
active equations
that they have to satisfy.
And that leaves n minus
R. That's the key point.
That's the key point that
there are n components of x--
n unknowns-- n unknowns.
And there are R constraints--
independent constraints.
So those n get--
if I want to satisfy those
constraints that knocks out
dimension R, and leaves
n minus R. So that's
the dimension here.
And the beauty of the count is
that those two numbers add up
to n.
Everybody's accounted for.
Every vector has a
piece in the row space
and a piece and the null space.
And that's-- those two pieces
give you back the vector.
Do you see that?
That's just nice, that the
numbers come out right.
And of course, they come
out right here, too.
You could say, just
transpose the matrix
and write it-- write
the same thing again.
What's the dimension
of the column space?
Equals?
The other column space in
the matrix has dimension--
AUDIENCE: R.
PROFESSOR: R. Right.
And the row-- this guy is left
out of some linear algebra
books, as if it doesn't belong.
But isn't it clear that
without it, everything
is only three quarters done?
We have to have this guy.
And its dimension is
AUDIENCE: M minus R.
PROFESSOR: M minus R. Yeah.
That count is just,
for A transpose, what
this count was for A. Yeah.
So we've got those dimensions,
R and n minus R, R and m
minus R. Yeah.
You'll have known
this, but we need
to see it once again in 2018,
before we start using it.
Now is that the
fundamental theorem?
Is that all to it there is?
No.
There is another piece to
the fundamental theorem,
which is, sort of you
could say, the geometry.
Here I have a sub space.
Here I have a subspace of
this big n dimensional space.
So I visualize those sub spaces
as some kind of a plane--
an R dimensional plane- and an
n minus R dimensional plane.
And I want to see how are
those two planes connected.
How are those two
planes connected?
And let me get a piece of the--
blank piece of the board
to remember the final step.
Right.
So we've got dimensions r and n
minus r, and then over here r,
and m minus r.
OK.
And this is for the rows.
This is for the null space.
So this has the rows in it.
This has the null--
the solutions to Ax equals 0.
What is the beautiful geometry--
how do you visualize
those two spaces?
How do you visualize?
Let me take an example.
Let A be 1, 2, 4, 2, 4, 8.
Sorry about that.
That's kind of a--
you see it hoked up example.
So this is 2 by 3.
So there n is 3.
What's in the null
space of this matrix?
Can you see a vector
that solves Ax equals 0?
And in fact, how
many will there be?
What's-- yeah, what's
r for this matrix?
Just tell me all the good stuff.
For that example, m is
2, n is 3, and r is--
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
Everybody sees 1 for the rank?
The rows are dependent.
There's only one
independent row.
The columns are dependent.
There's only-- every column
is a multiple of 1, 2.
It's a rank 1 matrix.
OK.
What about its-- so its
row space has dimension--
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
And it's null space
has dimension--
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: 2 So, cause
n minus r will be 2.
So I'm looking for a couple
of vectors that both give 0.
I believe there--
I think I've only got one
independent row there.
So I should be able to
find two different vectors
that solve Ax equals 0.
So what what's the
solution to Ax equals 0?
AUDIENCE: 0 minus 2, 1.
PROFESSOR: 0 minus 2, 1.
Yeah, that works.
And what's an
independent solution?
AUDIENCE: 4, 0, negative 1?
PROFESSOR: 4, 0--
don't throw me off--
4, 0 and--
AUDIENCE: Minus 1.
PROFESSOR: Minus 1.
Yeah.
That looks good.
And then the claim is
that every solution would
be a combination of those two.
And this is how many there are.
And now, it's the
geometry I'm completing.
So we have two minutes
left in this lecture.
You just have to tell me how--
what's the relation between
these guys in the row space,
and that guy in the null space?
What's the relation
between the rows of A,
the solutions to Ax equals 0?
Between-- if you see it-- if
you saw that vector and that
vector--
well, A times x is 0.
So what does that tell us?
What do we see for the
relation between 1, 2, 4, and 0
minus 2, 1.
AUDIENCE: Orthogonal
PROFESSOR: They are orthogonal.
Terrific.
Yes.
Orthogonal I test by the
dot product, 0 minus 4,
4, add to 0.
Yes.
So the-- and that's a
completely general fact.
When I look at Ax equals
0, it's telling me
that x is orthogonal
to the rows.
Do you see that?
Just to put it in again here.
If I look at Ax, A
has a bunch of rows.
X has one column.
And I get 0.
That's the point
of the null space.
And that equation is just
saying that row 1 is orthogonal,
because that's the dot
product of row 1 with x.
So here is row 1, row 2,
row 3, and row 4 with x.
The rows with x--
and I get 0s.
So the point is then, these two
spaces are at 90 degree angles.
That's really a neat picture
of the four sub spaces.
And these two are
for the same reason--
at 90 degree angles--
off in m dimensional space.
So this is the fundamental
theorem of linear algebra--
to see that the
dimensions come out right,
and the geometry
comes out right.
Yeah.
And then, now, next time--
following the notes-- and
I have a few more copies
of the one hand out.
We'll move on quickly next week
to eigenvalues and positive
definite matrices.
Good this is really
linear algebra moving on.